vous devez apprendre les règles du jeu
puis vous devez mieux jouer que tout le
monde
einstein c'est bien de connaître un
cours de trois cents pages parker de
connaître des références originales de
belles citations
c'est bien beau tout ça mais c'est quoi
la base la base c'est de connaître les
règles du jeu vous voulez réussir vos
dissertation de culture générale en
prépa hec et aux concours des écoles de
commerce
alors vous devez connaître les règles du
jeu de cette épreuve
[Musique]
l'épreuve de dissertation de culture
générale en prépa hec je la connais bien
parce que j prépare des élèves depuis
une dizaine d'années et chaque année je
leur reproche la même chose ils ne
connaissent pas assez voire pas du tout
les règles du jeu
or je voulais dit c'est la base qu'est
ce que la culture générale en prépa hec
quel est le programme
quelles sont les consignes précises
officiel de l'épreuve
quelles sont les statistiques des notes
de concours et les coefficients vous
devez connaître les réponses à ces
questions
ça tombe bien je vais tout vous
expliquer clairement et simplement
dans cette vidéo mais avant de commencer
je vous invite à vous inscrire à mon
cours gratuits de méthodologie de la
dissertation souhaite en cliquant sur le
lien qui apparaît maintenant en haut à
droite de la vidéo soit rang cliquant
sur celui qui est dans la description de
cette ville
c'est un cours par email très simple et
très pratique regardez ce que les élèves
de prépa hec en dise bon revenons aux
règles du jeu qu'est ce que je veux dire
par règles du jeu je vais vous dire dans
cette vidéo ce qui est précisément la
culture générale en prépa hec les
modalités de vos épreuves de
dissertation et enfin la notation et les
coefficients appliqués aux concours vous
savez combien de temps ça m'a pris pour
rassembler toutes ces informations
une après midi entière j'ai même appelé
hec pour obtenir des statistiques mais
vous vous saurez tout ce que vous avez
besoin de savoir en seulement 10 minutes
en regardant cette vidéo donc regarder
la attentivement et annie votre
téléphone préparez-vous à prendre des
notes et concentrez-vous c'est parti
[Musique]
commençons par le commencement
que dit le programme officiel l'arrêté
du 30 mai 2013 dit que l'enseignement de
la culture générale à trois objectifs
majeurs
il vise à développer chez les étudiants
à la maîtrise de l'expression écrite et
orale ainsi que l'aptitude à communiquer
compétences indispensables pour leur
future vie professionnelle
tiens tiens ça ressemble beaucoup à ce
que je répète il les entraîne à
approfondir leur réflexion personnelle
et leur sens critique
il leur permet d'enrichir leur culture
et de mieux comprendre le monde dans
lequel ils vivent
en synthèse le programme dit mieux
s'exprimer à l'écrit et à l'oral mieux
réfléchir et mieux comprendre le monde
donc contrairement à ce que semble
croire certains profs le but n'est pas
du tout de connaître dans les détails
les théories de plateau en termes de
culture le but c'est comme le dit
l'économiste jean marc daniel qui était
prof à vue est super le but c'est de
former l'esprit des futurs officiers de
la guerre économique de leur apprendre à
réfléchir avec rigueur à manipuler des
idées complexes et de leur donner une
certaine ampleur de vue eh bien oui une
école de commerce
ce n'est pas pour faire prof de philo
d'ailleurs la matière culture générale
ça ne se réduit pas à la philosophie en
prépa hec c'est surtout un mélange de
philosophie et de littérature comme le
précise le site d' hec d'ailleurs mais
en réalité toutes les connaissances qui
permettent de mieux comprendre le monde
sont pertinentes
l'histoire l'économie la psychologie le
droit et c'est plein de connaissances
différentes ont donc leur place dans
cette matière voilà pour les lignes
directrices de la culture générale on
prépare à chaud c'est maintenant quel
est le programme de la matière c'est à
dire qu'est ce que vous êtes censés
apprendre en culture générale en prépa
hec
alors est ce n'est pas la même chose en
première et en deuxième année
première année les cours de culture
générale certains consolidé à enrichir
le socle de connaissances constitué au
lycée de ce point de vue la matière est
un peu le prolongement du français et en
étudiant en 1ère et de la philosophie
étudiant en terminale
voici le programme précis de
première année l'héritage de la pensée
grecque et latine les apports du
judaïsme du christianisme et de l'islam
à la pensée occidentale les étapes de la
constitution des sciences exactes et des
sciences de l'homme
l'essor technologique l'idée de progrès
la société le droit et l'état moderne
les figures du mois et la question du
sujet depuis la renaissance l'esprit des
lumières et leur destin quelques grands
courants artistiques et esthétiques
depuis la renaissance les principaux
courants idéologiques contemporain alors
oui ça fait beaucoup mais on ne va pas
se mentir
la plupart des élèves de prépa hec ne
retiennent pas grand chose de ce
programme
pourquoi et bien parce qu'il ya un thème
en deuxième année
les différentes bandes de concours se
mettre d'accord sur un seul thème si
bien que tous les sujets des concours
porteront sur le même thème par exemple
c'était le désir en 2020 et c'est
l'animal en 2021
du coup ce n'est pas très rentable de
maîtriser le programme de bijoux
maintenant qu'est ce qu'on peut dire des
thèmes qui tombe et bien savary ce sont
parfois des notions très classique et
vasque qui sont même au programme de
philosophie de terminale comme la
science en 2007 où la nature en 2016
mais la notion est parfois précises
comme la sensibilité en 1999 où la
beauté en 2009
globalement ce sont toujours des idées
classique en philosophie voici tous les
thèmes qui sont tombés depuis 1991
voilà maintenant que vous savez ce qu'il
faut savoir sur la matière je vais vous
parler de l'épreuve la dissertation de
culture générale
[Musique]
soyons pragmatiques
voici à quoi ressemblera le sujet le
jour j au concours bon on n'apprend pas
grand chose sur l'épreuve en lisant le
sujet on lit qu'elle dure quatre heures
en l'occurrence de 14 heures à 18 heures
disons aussi le nota bene il sera tenu
compte des qualités de plans et
d'expositions ainsi que de la correction
de la langue il n'est fait usage d'aucun
document et l'utilisation de tout
matériel électronique n'est pas
autorisée sujet rappelle donc ce que dit
le programme
le plan c'est à dire l'organisation de
la pensée est l'expression écrite sont
importants et puis pas de documents ni
de matériel électronique
alors ça c'est un sujet tombé à
l'épreuve du concours d'entrée d' hec
mais comme vous le savez probablement il
y a trois épreuves principales celles
des écoles d' hec et aimions qui compte
aussi pour d'autres écoles celle des
écoles et sec et et d'hec et enfin celle
de la banque de concours ecricome
l'épreuve et clés comme a généralement
lieu à la mi avril puis celle de la bce
se tiennent fin avril début mai quelle
différence y at-il entre ces épreuves
ce sont toutes les trois des
dissertation de culture générale a
rédigé en quatre heures mais les sujets
hsv millions et avec l'essec sont
généralement plus difficile
tiens prenez 30 secondes pour regarder
les sujets tombés ces dernières années
autre différence entre les trois
épreuves a écrit comme vous aurez le
choix entre un sujet qui porte sur le
thème est un sujet hors thème qui porte
sur la totalité du programme de première
année
alors les sujets de ces trois épreuves
sont différents mais ces épreuves
partagent les mêmes qu'on manche
retenez en surtout 2 les correcteurs
s'attendent pas un plan dialectique en
trois parties avec trois sous parties
soit neuf parties au total ce n'est pas
obligatoire mais vous prendrez un risque
inutile en adoptant un autre type de
plan seconde convention c'est de
souligner les références pour permettre
aux correcteurs de les repérer
facilement dans la copie voilà vous
connaissez maintenant les consignes de
l'épreuve les différents sujets et les
conventions de l'épreuve
il est temps de parler des notes et des
coefficients
[Musique]
comme toutes les autres épreuves la
dissertation culture générale est notée
sur 20
mais étant donné la difficulté les
résultats sont habituellement inférieurs
à ceux des autres matières la différence
importante avec les autres et pop c'est
que le correcteur de la dissertation de
culture générale est libre dans
l'appréciation de la copie il ne suis
pas un barème précis
à ma connaissance ce qui renforce l'idée
de la loterie le premier numéro de ce
soir le voici le jury avec lit comme le
dit explicitement il n'y a pas à
proprement parler de barème pour la
dissertation culture générale donc si le
correcteur vous à la bonne
il peut vous sûr noté inversement s'il
ne vous sent pas il peut vous sac et
c'est pour ça que j'apprends à mes
élèves à écrire clairement un style
clair c'est le meilleur moyen de séduire
le correcteur et donc d'être sûr noté et
inversement
un mauvais style fait perdre des points
dans je vais vous apprendre à intégrer
hec emmanuel wail parle d'une double
peine il est fréquent qu'une copie
présentant un style fautifs soient
sanctionnés au delà même du barème prévu
à cet effet difficile effectivement pour
le correcteur en charge de noter une
copie fautive de dépasser la priori
négatifs cancre dans son esprit des
fautes constante et il est fréquent que
les erreurs de forme se paie également
en termes de crédibilité sur le fond le
tout se répercute bien évidemment sur
l'impression générale que donne votre
prestation et donc sur la note finale
donc
rappelez-vous le correcteur est libre
c'est à vous de le séduire par l'ons
note maintenant que disent les
statistiques faudrait pas aller dans le
détail ça ne sert à rien je vais vous
donner les grandes lignes pour ces
dernières années aux épreuves hec uem
union et et d'hec et sec
la moyenne est grosso modo autour de 10
pour les os et les oeufs et autour de 7
pour les sociétés vous pouvez aussi
retenir quand un élève sur dix et un
élève sur cette décroche plus de 15
autre information intéressante
environ 1 élève sur deux cents décroche
le graal 20 sur 20 et oui comme vous le
savez probablement les notes sont
étirées au concours ça permet de
discriminer les candidats
les correcteurs et et traditionnelle
sévère en culture générale mais depuis
des années 2000 les jurys font en sorte
de donner davantage de bonnes notes pour
que la moyenne de la matière soit
comparable à celle des autres matières
c'est pour ça qu au doigt mouillé
un élève sur 6 de cce atteindra la barre
d'admissibilité à hec et à l'essec en
culture générale
c'est à dire en termes de notes 13 14 ça
montre que ça n'a rien d'impossible
d'atteindre la barre d'admissibilité en
dissertation de culture générale par
ailleurs c'est encore moins difficile
d'atteindre les bars de l'union et de
l'edhec qui sont grosso modo à 12 et
demi même les candidats les plus faibles
peuvent en étant réaliste viser la
moyenne pour sauver les meubles quant à
l'épreuve décrit comme la banque ne
communique pas les statistiques
à ma connaissance mais j'imagine qu'elle
dise grosso modo les mêmes choses que
celle de la dcn alors après il y as not
et note
je veux parler des coefficients et oui
votre note en dissertation de culture
générale n'aura pas le même poids dans
toutes les écoles là aussi il ya pas mal
de spécificités donc je ne vais pas
entrer dans le détail mais seulement
vous donner les grandes lignes
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez retenir vous
pouvez d'abord retenir que les écoles
qui accordent le plus gros coefficient à
l'épreuve son hec l'essec et puis quel
âge
ensuite vous pouvez retenir que les
écoles qui accordent le plus faible
coefficient à l'épreuve son grenoble
école de management toulouse
audencia skema et montpellier après le
coefficient change non seulement en
fonction de l'école mais aussi en
fonction de la filière
donc ça fait beaucoup de coefficients
différents pour simplifier les choses
vous pouvez retenir que la dissertation
de culture générale pèse grosso modo un
sixième de la moyenne des concours dans
la hiérarchie des épreuves elle passe
après les mathématiques l'économie pour
les os et e
la géopolitique pour les ecs le
management et sciences de gestion pour
les sociétés et elle est placée sur le
même niveau que la lv1 par certaines
écoles audencia par exemple c'est grosso
modo la troisième épreuve la plus
importante des concours
[Musique]
voilà vous savez tout sur la
dissertation de culture générale en
prépa hec
si vous deviez retenir uniquement trois
choses je vous dirais de retenir que
l'expression écrite est une dimension
fondamentale de cette épreuve que la
note qu'on grosso modo pour un sixième
de la moyenne au concours même si comme
je voulais dit le coefficient varie
selon les écoles et les filières
troisième chose à retenir
vous avez lu les sujets c'est une
épreuve difficile vous ne devez donc pas
la prendre à la légère sinon vous allez
vous ramassez en particulier vous avez
besoin d'une méthodologie solide
inscrivez vous donc à mon cours gratuits
de méthodologie pouvez vous y inscrire
soit en cliquant sur le lien qui
apparaît maintenant haut à droite de la
vidéo soit en cliquant sur le lien qui
est dans la description cette vidéo bien
sûr si vous avez des questions sur la
dissertation de culture générale en
prépa hec
n'hésitez pas à me les poser dans les
commentaires je vous répondrai avec
plaisir voilà voilà
j'espère que cette vidéo vous sera utile
parce que comme le dit einstein il faut
connaître les règles du jeu pour mieux
jouer que les autres je suis romain je
suis toujours avec mon fidèle aristote
qui la voit en train de dormir
rappelez vous que vous n'avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête pour cartonner
en dissertation culture générale en
prépa hec
[Musique]
oh
bon
[Musique]